five nights at freddys is an accidental
phenomenon the likes of which the world
has never known since the first game's
release in 2014 the hit horror series
has become a gaming sensation that
spawned sequels a spin-off tie-in toys
multiple novels and now thanks to Blum
house productions and writer director
Chris Columbus a feature film with a
track record that includes gremlins and
The Goonies the filmmaker sounds like a
perfect fit for the series twisted brand
of horror comedy all the elements for a
great horror flick are there they just
have to be used right here are all the
things we're hoping to see in five
nights at freddys light of the morning
while the details are always different
each five nights at freddy's game boils
down to one goal surviving the night
whether it's a lonely late shift
security guard or a terrified kid in
their bedroom each games protagonist is
stuck having to do everything they can
to bat back the monsters hunting them
their only salvation 6 a.m. many of the
game's most white-knuckle moments come
in the last stretch of each level before
morning after all your resources have
been exhausted and the only thing that
can save you is the clock so obviously
the movie would do well to follow the
same rules a harried hero in a horrid
situation pushed to the edge of being
slaughtered by monsters which become
harmless at the first glimpse of morning
a helpless hero getting saved by the
clock will go a long way toward making
the movie feel like the game especially
if we get a few of the best scares right
near the end of 5 a.m.
[Music]
hello-hello for five nights at freddys
fans the voice of the phone guy is an
essential part of the fazbear experience
Everly blending exposition with
instruction the phone guys messages set
the tone for each night with chipper yet
ominous warnings about the players
duties creating a sense of isolation
that shouldn't be discarded in the
translation to film it's pretty much a
no-brainer to include phone guy for
spooling out the series weird lore and
would also be a perfect fit for a cameo
appearance from the games developers and
original phone guy voice scott cawthon
hearing a tired coffin on the other end
of the line would be a nice nod to the
man who laid the foundation for a
phenomenon so remember these characters
hold a special place in the hearts and
children
okay foxy and friends it almost goes
without saying that a five nights at
Freddy's movie isn't going to work
unless Freddy brings the whole crew
inspired by the real-life arcade in
animatronics Pizza franchise
chuck-e-cheeses the five nights at
Freddy's series includes a whole
extended family of animatronic
entertainers and the movie would do well
to invite them all something jumping out
of the dark and grabbing you can get old
so the series animatronics all have
different attributes in the Chucky s
creepy child category there's Balloon
Boy and the wholesome yet homicidal baby
for eerie haunted circus ambience
there's the dancing Valora and the
clownish marionette the fleet-footed
foxy and the unsettling two theta are as
menacing as any slasher villain all of
these characters bring a different scary
skill set to the table especially if
they get the chance all of five nights
for to go into nightmare mode put a
quarter up one of the least talked about
aspects of the five night series is the
stuff that goes down between the levels
since the first entry the series has
featured little interludes of simple
Atari style minigames most of which seem
pretty normal on the surface the happy
vibe of the minigames stands in stark
contrast to the pitch-black horror of
the main game and also setup scares of
their own when the games take turns that
are unexpectedly grim haunted video
games have often been the stuff of
crappy creepypasta but they could serve
a purpose in the five nights movie
especially if the film is set in an
arcade that's open for business it's
against the series rules to have
animatronics talk the halls during
business hours so having the cloying
kids games take subtle dark twists could
be a great way to unsettle an audience
in the early going it's important to
know that at Freddy fazbear's a game
over really means something
[Music]
home delivery five nights at freddys for
moved the action from a pizzeria to the
bedroom of one of the franchise's little
guests making it by far the scariest
entry in the series with the monster
designs going above and beyond the rest
of the games in terms of sheer horror
while the red light green light gameplay
remained the same the sense of Violation
the monsters caused went to a whole new
level it's bad enough to eviscerate kids
at the arcade but hunting them down in
their bedrooms that's just terrifying
and if it's done right could make for
the movie's most sinister scenes it's me
the biggest scares can come from the
stuff you don't see coming one of the
game's more unpredictable elements is
gold and Freddy a variation on
everyone's favorite killer bear that
will occasionally appear with no regard
to the rules if the player doesn't shake
him off in time the game itself crashes
and resets the effect is truly
unsettling kicked out of the game and
left staring at your desktop you may
feel that the evil spirits are loose in
your computer the movie could emulate
this by messing with the fourth wall
taking a page out of the Exorcist book
the movie could assault the audience
with subliminal imagery or like in the
sequel to Columbus's gremlins the
monsters could just burn up the film
print breaking out of the movies world
to jump out of the screen
[Music]
the bite of 87 if there's one scene that
five Knights fanatics will be expecting
to see in the movie it's probably the
most infamous bite of 87 first
referenced by the phone guy in the first
game this brutal animatronic attack
quickly became a legendary focal point
in five nights at freddys lore serving
as the moment freddy fazbears went from
a fun franchise to something much more
evil of the series spent months
speculating about the nature of the
fateful bite before the fourth game
finally showed it players who reached a
certain minigame were able to watch as
the small child's head was crushed in a
pair of animatronic jaws the carnage
being portrayed in old-school pixelated
fashion if the film brings this to life
the right way it'll both thrill fans and
leave parents everywhere wondering how
they ever thought these games were safe
for kids thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to